[Música]
muchas veces el mayor deseo de los
chicos y las chicas que tienen alguna
discapacidad intelectual es ser
independientes ser autónomos no depender
de nadie a lo largo de su vida
de hecho hace muy poco una joven que
tiene síndrome de down me decía que su
sueño era viajar sola en subte desde
estación congreso a plaza de mayo de una
cabecera de a otra sola
la tecnología y a poco está permitiendo
que estos sueños se empiecen a hacer
realidad como desde la educación porque
nos permite respetar sus tiempos
respetar sus necesidades hoy a través de
la realidad virtual y la inteligencia
artificial estamos siendo capaces de
simular situaciones con los chicos que
ellos después van a vivir desde ir a un
médico o ir al dentista hasta incluso
algo más complejo por ejemplo una
operación de forma que cuando
efectivamente eso pase
esos estén preparados para reaccionar
esto es muy importante el poder predecir
los hechos es muy importante no sólo
para ellos sino también para todo el
entorno es más si hay unos primeros
prototipos de ropa en particular
camperas que a través de sensores son
capaces de predecir vieron esos
berrinches esos enojos que a veces
tienen los chicos que realmente que
tienen autismo bueno son capaces de
precios para ayudarlos antes de que
suceda
las redes sociales hoy a través de las
redes los chicos están saliendo del
aislamiento pueden compartir sus
experiencias es más están resultando
fundamentales para lo que tiene que ver
con la inclusión laboral de las personas
con discapacidad que es algo dicho sea
de paso que está creciendo a nivel
mundial
por último con las apariciones de las
llamadas casas inteligentes hoy estamos
empezando a pensar que ellos y ellas de
mayores van a empezar a poder vivir
solos la internet de las cosas está que
escuchamos lo que permite es a diseñar
dispositivos que evitan accidentes que
facilitan la comunicación incluso hacen
más fácil la administración de
diferentes aspectos de un hogar de una
casa actitud de integrar a todas a todas
las personas en una sociedad eso es
incluir la buena noticia es que a través
de la tecnología lo vamos a ir logrando
muchas gracias
[Música]